so here is a legitimate observation
about the need to relieve ourselves from
socialization from you might call the
membrane of invisible instructions that
are imposed upon us by our cultural
operating system we're kind of all
swimming in an invisible fluid that
permeates and informs our cave
an example would be the set of basic
rules or principles that are applicable
in a shared environment like you're out
in public interacting with other people
there's a set of sort of codes of
behavior there's a set of ethical
guidelines what I think often happens is
that the weight of those instructions
the weight of that socialization it's
embedded really deep right the the
social and cultural operating system
that surrounds us can be insidious in
its capacity to penetrate our be and I
think from that penetration our neurosis
emerges
Sigmund Freud the psychologist famously
talked about the it the ego and the
super it is of course you're you're sort
of virginal and raw personality
you see something that you want you make
a grasp for you respond to the world in
a dynamic way without inhibition you
want what you want you repel what you do
not want there is a sense that what is
what is disliked can be and must be
avoided and what is enjoyed it must be
enjoyed with exactitude and ferocious
intense that is the end but eventually
the it'd comes under assault from the
forces of the outside the rules and
regulations and closes my family and my
culture it's the beginning of being told
no don't play with your food you know
don't be all over yourself don't do this
don't do that don't don't don't put your
finger in the electric outlet and I get
it right we're we're shaped into place
by these external forces of culture and
family these rules start to get imposed
constriction upon the it because the
it'd longs to be unrestrained the it'd
longs to be without constriction to
express itself fully to take what it
wants to live without any kind of
instructions right to be virginal and
wry and living in the Garden of Eden
right and and of course as the forces
from the outside as I've said start to
start to penetrate the membrane of our
being that becomes what's known as the
super-ego so that's where guilt comes
from where neurosis comes from where
unhappiness and dissatisfaction comes
from because eventually we are neutered
from those external forces they rob us
of our vitality they rob us of our
creativity under the guise of robbing us
of our madness and our wildness you know
the guise of socialization we are
educated into submission you know we are
slowly digging our own grave with the
assistance of these instructions from
the forces of the outside so that's the
super-ego and then the ego is that
fragile house of cards that construction
the character structure we try to build
between your desire to express yourself
actualize yourself steer your eyes your
inner landscape and make manifest
yourself and your dreams and your
yearnings and your longing so on and so
forth
the ego is slowly walking the tightrope
between those broad desires it's
constricting forces of the outside the
constantly say no you may not know you
can no you're not good enough you'll
never make it
no you can't behave this way in public
and no you can't do this no you can't do
that no you can't do this no you can't
do that until we are especially those of
us that aren't able to rebel against
which we are imprisoned right and we are
often blind to our prisoners it's the
worst kind of jail is the kind of
indentured servitude where you don't
really even realize that you're a slave
and when people start to question this
dog more people start to try to free
themselves of this how do I call it when
people try to free themselves at this
program this cultural program people try
to dissolve these limiting beliefs are
these boundaries that have embedded
themselves in every fabric of our being
they become rebel may become revolutions
they become the it's the radiating
bastards they become the ecstatic poets
that stand up on the summit of the
mountain and say
all those people we celebrate these
people and we love how eloquent those
people are we love what's known as the
infectiousness of the uncollected man we
love the the Tyler Durden Fight Club or
or the Bodie character for a Point Break
we love those three spirits who remind
us of the freedom that we have given up
they remind us of the life that we might
have lived if we hadn't succumbed to the
imposition of limiting beliefs and
constrictions from a girl that wants to
keep you small and I often am reminded
of this when I finally in spite of
myself
slipstream into a state of consciousness
from which I am free from my neuroses
and when I am free from my neurosis life
is so much more present so much more
ferocious in its intensity there's a
heightened qualitative intensity
heightens feelings feeling of aliveness
a heightened engagement a sense of first
sight unencumbered by knowing this
transitory enchanted moments take my
breath would compel me into states of
consciousness in which I am face-to-face
with something could measure it to my
capacity for me for a wonder I when I
break through those maps and I'm in the
territory beyond the maps it feels like
liberation bill feels like vision
earring it feels like divination in
those moments glimpse a world beyond the
grid the matrix of limitations that have
been pulled in front of my eyes we love
those films like the matrix
get those alchemists those philosopher
Kings those that whisper in our ears to
escape so
I hope you find your way out of the
Truman Show I hope you find your way
back to a more authentic life I hope you
find a pathway to the to the treasure
you know at the end of the rainbow I
hope you follow the yellow brick road I
hope you chase the rabbit down the
rabbit hole and I hope you find what you
are looking for free
[Music]